online videos und bilder auf foto
portalen
sie werden täglich millionenfach ins
netz gestellt der zugang zu solchen
informationen bleibt usern mit handicap
oft verwehrt ihren lühr erblindete im
alter von 20 jahren an den folgen einer
netzhautablösung um surfen zu können
greift der informatiker aus dresden auf
hilfsmittel zurück wenn er die
nachrichten verfolgt dann klingt das zum
beispiel so überschrift gelöschter krise
gibt für griechenland steuert auf die
pleite zu ein sogenannter screen reader
liest ihm den inhalt der website vor
gleichzeitig überträgt das programm die
texte auch auf eine tastatur für blinde
doch viele webseiten sind nicht
barrierefrei programmiert
da hilft auch die software nicht weiter
webseiten tendieren immer dazu zuviel
darzustellen lösen überladen man hat
immer mal über 1000 links auf einer
webseite oder sie ist überhaupt nicht
zugänglich für den screen reader so dass
ich da einfach überhaupt nicht hinkomme
und da gibt es immer wieder sachen auf
verschiedensten webseiten wo man dann
einfach einstellen stößt wo man nicht
weiter können der software-entwickler
setzt deshalb auf sein smartphone
die menüführung ist oft übersichtlicher
die bedienung dank sprachsteuerung
einfacher jan lühr hat nun sogar seine
eigene app entwickelt der kaller wie
sehr hilft dabei farben zu erkennen
sehr praktisch zum beispiel beim kochen
es geht ja nicht nur darum dass man
irgendwelche apps entwickelt für blinde
damit jetzt irgendwas ausgeglichen wird
sondern eben wirklich auch darum dass
möglichst alle zumindest jetzt sagen wir
mal als als utopie alle apps im
benutzbar sind barrierefrei gemacht sind
smartphone-apps können nicht nur für
blinde eine stütze sein
kevin lücke aus hamburg hat you go
mitentwickelt eine digitale stadtführung
für touristen
neben audio guide bietet die app auch
videos in gebärdensprache an
so können auch gehörlose mehr über
sehenswürdigkeiten erfahren
in fünf europäischen metropolen ist der
service nutzbar
darunter auch berlin und wien nur die
möglichkeit über fax zu kommunizieren
oder e-mail kommunizieren und schrift
ist auch immer so schritt spart das
immer ein schwieriges thema auch eine
ganze sache jetzt gibt's natürlich die
möglichkeit auf und videotelefonie
wie bei uns auch die gebärdensprache z
da sind natürlich die smartphones ein
unglaublich wichtiges werkzeug gerade
für gehörlose menschen auch für schwer
körperbehinderte soll das internet
zugänglich sein
das projektteam aus südkorea wurde von
einem technikkonzern ins leben gerufen
querschnittsgelähmte können dabei mit
einer hightech brille per augenbewegung
im computer steuern auf dem weg zur
barrierefreiheit sind die technischen
möglichkeiten längst nicht ausgeschöpft
das meint netzaktivist alexander sander
wenn wir wirklich ein bisschen weiter in
die zukunft blickt dann geht es glaube
ich klar in die tendenz dass
neurowissenschaftliche entwicklung hier
einzug erhalten werden also es ist jetzt
schon möglich gehirnaktivitäten zu
scannen und damit auch bestimmte
eingaben oder ausgaben vorzunehmen und
es wird möglich sein dass wir mit
unseren gedanken entsprechend zum
beispiel computer steuern können und das
natürlich für gerade menschen die eine
behinderung haben eine große
erleichterung
bis dahin bleibt für jan lühr das
smartphone das wichtigste hilfsmittel
der 39 jährige hofft künftig damit auch
seine haushaltsgeräte alleine bedienen
zu können
bisher mussten dass seine frau und sein
fünfjähriger sohn übernehmen
shift meint das internet ist für alle da